♪ Attention, attention ♪
♪ Y'a un plus fou
qui te pique ta folie ♪
- Daniel Lavoie, cet entretien
a lieu le jour de votre fête,
donc, tout d'abord,
a a a anniversaire.
- Merci, merci.
- Vous êtes né à 250 km
de Saint-Boniface.
- Oui.
- À Dunrea.
- Qu'est-ce que, justement,
le Manitoba vous a donné
pour que vous puissiez devenir
un artiste accompli?
DANIEL LAVOIE,
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- Écoute, indirectement,
probablement tout. Parce que...
j'ai à peu près...
anananannées formatives sont qud
même les années, les premières
années. Je dirais qu'à partir
du moment où je suis arrivé
au Québec, je pense que j'avais
sensiblement le bagage
que j'ai utilisé après
pour le restant de ma vie.
♪ J'ai quitté mon arbre ♪
♪ On est venu le couper ♪
- Vous êtes un grand timide.
Ça n'a pas dû être facile.
Vous êtes arrivé au Québec,
là où vous devez rencontrer
des gens, tenter de faire votre
place dans la chanson,
où il y en avait déjà beauc
d'artistes francophones,
au Québec.
- Oui, effectivement. Un grand
timide parce que tous les
Franco-Manitobaidedededededes
grands timides. Vous avez vécu
au Manitoba, vous savez, la
plupart des Franco-Manitobains
ont un... Si vous avez lu
"La dél'l'l'l'l'l'enchantement",
vous savez qu'on a tous un petit
complexe d'infériorité. On fait
pas trop de bruit, on dérange
pas, on fait notre vie. Et puiÇe
de moi. J'ai grandi comme ça.
J'ai grandi dans un pays,
dans un village ou il y avait
autant d'anglophones que de
francophones. Donc, on apprend
à être... à être plus
tranquille. Donc, j'étais timide
sans vraiment l'être. Je me suis
rendu compte avec les années
que j'étais pas aussi timide
que je pensais l'être.
♪ Qu'ils s'aiment
comme des enfants ♪
- Parmi vos grands succès,
il y a "Ils s'aiment",
"Jour de plaine" et ma préférée,
c'est "Je voudrais voir
New Yorkz z z z z z z que c'est
une grande chanson lors du
mixage final de cette
chanson-là?
- Non, j'ai jamais su qu'une
chanson allait marcher.
C'est à une époque où je...
je cherchais beaucoup.
J'osais des... des accords qui
étaient un petit peu hors norme,
qui étaient, si vous écoutez
le refrain, "coule-moi,
coule-moi au fond de toi",
c'était pas quelque choseaiaiaip
à l'époque. Euh...
C'est certain, même quand j'ai
fait "Ils s'isisisisisisisis pas
envie de mettre cette chanson-là
sur l'album. Pour moi, c'est une
chanson trop intime. Je sentais
pas que c'était un "hit".
Absolument pas. Il y a pas
de refrain, il y avait rien.
Et finalement, c'est devenu
la chanson la plus connue
de mon répertoire, donc j'avoue
que pour "New York", je le
savais pas du tout non plus.
♪ Je n'ai jamais vu New York ♪
- Depuis 1998, vous avez chanté
partout dans le monde dans la
comédie musicale "Notre-Dame
de Paris". Vous avez participé
à 1000 représentations.
- Oui.
- Comment pourriez-vous nous
décrire cette expérience-là?
- Au début, c'était un petit
un délire parce que
"Notre- Dame" était "big",
"big", "big", ça vibrait comme
ça. C'était un peu dif
et à la limite
de l'insupportable.
(rire de Louis-Philippe)
Mais maintenan
beaucoup plus cool, et j'avoue
que j'y prends énormément
de plaisir.
♪ Qui a mis dans mon être
ce désir charnel ♪
- Quand ça
"Notre-Dame de Paris", c'était
complètement fou. Vous étiez
des superstars en France.
- Ah, ouais, on était
itititititititititit vraiment
de la folie. À l'époque,
je me souviens, il y avait
1000 personnes qui nous
attendaient à la fin des, , , ,r
pour les échapper,
leur échapper. C'était vraiment
un délire absolument incroyable.
Une de mes anecdotes quejejejej,
c'est que quand on arrivait
au théâtre le soir, parce que, t
au Palais des congrès justement.
Et il y avait toujours 500
ou 600 personnes qui attendaienr
des autographes, des photos,
etc. Et il fallait passer
à travers. On n'avait paslelelee
tout ça. Donc, on avait trouvé
le système qui fonctionnait
le plus merveilleusement.
On sortait nos téléphones et on
faisait comme si on parlait.
uiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiui, oui,
oui, oui." Puis, on arrivait là
puis on fermait nos téléphones,
et les gens nous laissaient ç ç.
Et on l'a fait soir après soir,
et ça marchait tout le temps.
- Bon, Daniel Lavoie, il y a
cette nouvelle compilation,
mais à quand un nouvel albums s?
- Écoute, il est en train
de se faire en ce moment.
J'ai écrit un album dans
ce que j'appellerais le stylemyu
avec mon oncle quand j'étais
au Manitoba. Mon oncle écoutait
Jimmy Rogers, le vieux chanteur
de country, et j'ai écrit
une dizaine de chansons
à la Jimmy Rogers en anglais.
m m m m m m m m m m m mon fils,
qui... qui fait de la musique
et qui maîtrise très bien
la matière musicale, de réaliser
l'album. Donc, je suis en trainm
de folk "songs" en anglais,
avec une guitare acoustique
et des cuivres, qui va peut-être
sortir u
Ça a pas été fait pour sortir,
mais on sait jamais.
- J'ai vraiment hâte
d'entendre ça. Merci beaucoup,
Daniel Lavoie.
- Merci à vous.
♪ Chante, chante tout ce
t'as dans le ventre ♪
♪ Une passe de guitare
et un beau solo ♪
♪ Chante, chante une toune